[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the public
space today we will be having a
discussion with our friend bill gayde
about black holes in general but in
particular this new picture of a black
hole
which is such a an amazing picture and
it brings such data from outer worlds I
hope you saw the lights bill are you
here tonight to tell us that you deny
the theory of Roth's and that you've
been convinced of gravity by seeing this
wonderful doughnut in the sky given the
blurriness of the picture I have to say
I came to mad I can't do anything else
but laugh at the idea that some people
did pull the champagne on this picture
this picture of a video matter of an
irregular isometric donut they got a
Nobel Prize for doing you know gravity
to black holes absolutely and have you
been hearing from the LIGO there are
constant developments there they always
have signals that they seem to interpret
as gravity waves what's your take on
these legal results I said did believe
in gravity waves you wrote a paper
against it Nathan Rosen his buddy
insisted till the end of his life after
Einstein died that there were no such
things as gravity waves how these people
infer that to hold two black holes
collided billions of years ago and
suddenly you know when you receive the
gravity waves here you know they could
be talking about angels for all we care
well but from the moment you can have
higher gravity and lower gravity and I
hope you would agree with me on this
you can have waves I mean you could have
someone playing with the gravity with
the gravitational force such that it's
higher sometime lower sometime higher
sometimes lower sometimes
gravity gravity can be stronger and can
be weaker that doesn't mean that it's
mediated by transverse waves or
longitudinal waves that is true that is
true that there must be some sort of a
rope or a system of waves that could
carry these in the form of waves I don't
even know what's carrying gravitational
waves and their theories they don't have
they don't have in fact that's how I
wanted to start the discussion
they don't have explanations that's the
problem with mathematical physics for
the last 400 years there are no
explanations there are no mechanisms
what they have is mass they have they
talk about concepts such as field and
energy but they don't have a mechanism
they can't tell you a physical mechanism
you know if you look at that first
picture that I sent you number one I
think that pretty much tells you the
difference between mathematics what I
call mathematics and real physics and
the difference is that you know a
mathematician does I call him you know
he can go in there and tell you what a
plus B is he can tell you that the
magician on stage who was cutting the
lady in half you know used 20 strokes of
the saw he did in 10 seconds cut her
into two pieces you know he can go into
the numbers that's not an explanation
that's not a mechanist
and that's what we're math mad
mathematical physics fails physics is
what you see on the right hand side in
red and that's you know the guy
explaining to you a mechanism here you
have three different mechanisms of how
he how he could have cut her in half
one the ladies underneath has her lower
half of her body underneath the stage
and another one there's two ladies etc
okay
so the point is that these are mechanism
these are how they trick you this is how
they fooled you the other one's just a
description and mathematics can only
describe can only do what's on the left
and that's what they've done you know
when these people say that
LIGO detected gravity waves or that they
took a picture of a black hole all
they're doing is salya propaganda you
know that they're not explaining
anything all they're doing is saying
look we took a picture that proves our
theory what theory
I need a theory of how gravity works and
that's what we don't have and I mean by
gravity works I mean mechanisms you know
this side I'm not I agree with you there
are two levels of explanation one is a
descriptive one simply state what
happened or what will happen and the
other is a mechanistic one that seeks to
find what underlies what we don't see in
the mechanism that we observe and I'm
saying I go deeper than that a little
deeper than that I'm saying that
discrete you just used the word
description I'm saying description has
nothing to do with explanations
explanation has nothing to do with
description describe I described a chair
it's brown it's got four legs see a
backrest that's that's a description an
explanation is you know when you explain
the mechanism in other words you you
tell the person how something was done
you want to explain how a car works you
make pictures you make a movie of your
of your mechanism and the guy watches
the movie and he can understand how a
car runs just by watching the movie and
you won't find that in all of
mathematical physics there is not a
single explanation and I'll tell you why
the reason is they insist on the
particle hypothesis that's the reason
why they can't they can't explain
anything with a particle or with waves
and that's why we're stuck with
descriptions so I'd like to dig a little
more on this so I can understand because
I've been shaking my own beliefs and
particles recently I've been discussing
with our friend quantum physicist Peter
and at this point I'm not even sure if
if I believe that there are
because I believe only and wave bill
here's a way okay you see the wave no
but but seriously you're saying they are
insisting on a particle model who's
insisting the quantum physicist even
general relativity is a particle theory
because general relativity as well
special relativity focuses on on the
photon and the photon is treated as a
particle as a discrete particle okay so
if you say if you ask a roughness right
say well what is light you'll say it's a
flow of bullets you know it's a flow of
particles and are those classical
corpuscles
oh no and that's when they start with
the hocus pocus they say well zero
dimension oh it's got no mass you know
they go to numbers you never see a
picture whatever picture you put is
wrong all right now is there such a
thing as what people are asking on the
regular chat and before we jump into the
the subject of black holes about the
rope theory is there such a thing as
cutting a rope can you break one of your
ropes if you look throughout the
internet you won't find my answer to
that question and there's a purpose for
that so we have an exclusive exclusive
subject tonight on the public space you
won't find it on the internet because I
don't want it on the internet and
there's their reason for that the reason
is that I discuss those issues with
people who are familiar with the
scientific method 99.99 percent of the
people out there are not familiar with
the scientific method they don't know
what a word what the word object means
they don't know what an object is and
you can't do physics without an object
they don't they're not familiar with the
foundations of physics they don't know
what the word exists means they don't
know what touch means what you would
need to
explain that so they would not be able
to understand my my answer unless they
go through the difficult process of
understanding the foundations of physics
and most people are not familiar with
them so people won't you know we're
wasting our time if I explain the guy
didn't understand because he's trying to
he's trying to visualize this maybe in
terms of mathematics energy mass fields
and I'm gonna explain with objects I'm
gonna say look this this is a rock this
is a tree this is a dog you know and
they're not familiar with that they say
well you know I want you to talk to me
in terms of I understand that's not the
way it works they're gonna have to learn
it the way I understand it and that's
with objects alright so thank thank us
through the black hole thing what you
believe on it because I don't think that
you deny the the phenomena that are
described as gravity and mass but you
tend to have a different interpretation
so take us through whatever it is that
you prepare for tonight okay the first
thing is that again I'm saying that
mathematics and this offends a lot of
people you know mathematics has
absolutely nothing to do with physics
and people immediately you know they
want to hang me for saying this but
there's a reason for me saying that and
this is the reason I say science is
about explanations mathematics can only
describe therefore mathematics has
nothing to do with science or with
physics okay that's the rationale that's
why I keep saying math has nothing to do
with science or with physics and so when
people ask questions relating to energy
mass what is the distance we don't care
we don't care because that doesn't
explain anything I don't explain
anything by using the word time I don't
explain anything by using the word
energy especially if the word energy has
never been defined I cannot explain what
we have the subject of today anything
using the word mass because the word
mass has never been defined you know and
here I'll just give you a quick quote if
I may
that'll put it in in the right
perspective this is from Edwin Taylor
and John Wheeler
some people haven't heard of these guys
but they were physicists I think I've
been Taylor might still be alive but
John Wheeler died a couple years ago I
think is they say the following in
space-time physics their book listen to
this it says nature does not offer us
any concept as the amount of matter
history has struck down every proposal
to define such a term even if we could
count number of atoms or by any other
counting method try to evaluate amount
of matter that number would not equal
mass there is no definition of the word
mass today the wikipedia has seven
different definition then they say
choose the one you want you know
whatever mass means to you that you use
it so we don't have a definition of mass
we don't have a definition energy we
don't know what time is but people want
answers in those terms there's a way so
I was don't I agree I'm personally being
red-billed of the subject of mass
recently because I've been watching lots
of YouTube videos essentially I need any
definition of mass you use it appears
the mass of a given object that you
don't touch will change according to
where it is according to its level of
energy its heat its movement if it moves
it stops having the same mass so we have
to have been done the concept of mass as
a measure of the universe gravitational
mass you have relativistic mass they
created all these masses because they
they use them ad hoc they use it
whatever mass they need for whatever
purpose they need you know and and and
this is a serious problem you have the
extremes you have a photon which is a
zero dimensional non entity that has no
mass and you have a black hole which is
a zero that mention a zero dimensional
non entity which has I don't know
infinite mass I guess because if it's
got zero volume I guess you know math
should be infinite but they very high
mass so yeah very high or close to
infinitesimal in the other direction you
know so sorry
so the
but I still don't understand the
mechanism because you know I don't have
any mechanism from mathematical physics
of how mass affects a star far away I
need to know how mass a concept
kilograms right how that bends
space-time another concept which doesn't
exist just a four four number lines
which they call back mentions they're
not dimensions they're not coordinates
they're known as number lines they take
four number lines they turn it into four
dimensional object which are not
supposed to see as an object because
it's just an analogy you know and so
it's so you're not supposed to visualize
this you're just supposed to say look
you can only understand it through math
but there's no understanding because
there's no explanation all you have is a
description and what is the description
the description is that you have mass
runaway mass bending space-time and
somehow that affects a star far away
well out of the three objects that we
just talked about the only real object
is a star far away there is no such
thing as mass and there is no such thing
as space-time and I've got a little old
gift there that I sent you
it's number let's see look at number 19
all right
you put number 19 20 and 21 one after
another here's number 19 right we have
an elephant in a ditch in a depression
and we have a little turtle that's going
around it because you know them
supposedly this is what a black hole is
a big mass in the center weighing down
space-time in this case you know made a
depression in the ground and you have
the turtle going around now we replace
the elephant with the word mass in other
words we we get rid of the structure we
got rid of the elephant we only have his
kilograms is six tons so we have six
tons weighing down a depression and the
turtles going around the six tons okay
no longer all around an elephant now why
don't you put number of 20 the next one
okay now now we replaced the ground with
space-time we got rid of the ground
which was real now we have space-time
which is another concept we have mass a
concept weighing down you know we got
rid of that ground no more ground now we
have space-time okay in a second here
look there it goes
so now we have a concept weighing down
another concept and the turtle going
around who knows what around mass and if
you take the next one number 21 we got
rid of mass we get rid of the space-time
net the fishnet and what do we have we
have a turtle going around nothing
essentially that's mathematics there
that's that's what you've got to learn
if you go to college they're gonna say
oh we don't know the mechanism or still
investigated we only have a turtle going
around nothing around two concepts
concert was nothing not nothing
a black hole is something well is it
something that's that's the other
question we have if you look at which
one is it
look at the first picture first number
10 look at number 10 that's the picture
that that they published right so what
are we staring at here we look at that
dark smudge in the center of that orange
halo and they say well that's an event
horizon with what you have is matter
gases falling into the event horizon
right that's what they say we have okay
now here's a million-dollar question for
any mathematician who is willing to
answer it because I'm sure none of them
will and that's number go with the next
one number 11 all right so what are we
staring at are we staring at a hole a
two-dimensional rabbit hole that takes
you to another universe or are we
looking at a ball that stands in the
middle of the cosmic ocean see in the
case of the
whole the only way you can see that hole
is if you're your god and you're outside
of space-time or outside of space and
you're looking at the surface of space
only then can you see the hole on the
other hand if you're looking at the ball
yeah you can look at it inside the
center of a cosmic ocean
you know like like you see a fish inside
the water but we have a difference
between these two notions here the first
one is gravity taking you to another
universe right and the second one the
ball it's gravity takes you to the
center of the ball to that singularity
so which is it which are is is gravity
flowing through through a hole that
takes you through a wormhole or is
gravity something that takes you to the
center of the ball which opens to chance
is a black hole I will speak for
classical physics here and I will say
that the general view is that it's a 3d
bowling ball a black hole from the
outside now from the inside you can
imagine anything you want you can
imagine that it leads to such a peak in
the space-time that it brings you
somewhere else or even creates another
universe at the end but as far as our
interaction with it we can rotate around
it in a 3d space around the ball well I
would say that you watch too many
Hollywood movies that's what I would say
this is so realistic there's no way you
can reconcile a singularity single
singularity at the center of a ball
right which is what a star collapsed to
it collapsed a small ball in fact you
have the definitions there if you look
at number which one is it oh look at
number 13 yeah that's that's what I want
no that one no the one you just had that
that's wrong right look at the
definition that NASA gives you and look
at the one that on the right which gives
you which is given by the Max Planck
Institute one treated as a physical
object as a ball the other one treats it
as a concept that you say it's a region
of something else region can only be of
something else a ball can is a
standalone object so a region is not a
ball and a ball is not a region so they
have to decide which is it you know are
we gonna talk about a ball or you gonna
talk about a hole what is what I will I
will deny this a region can be a ball
and in fact any object can be defined as
a region in space region is a concept
look it up region is a content region is
not a ball - the moment you admit that
there is such a thing as the surface of
an object then the object can be
confined to a region of any universe
region is a concept you can't replace
the word ball with the word region no
way no way a region is not a standalone
object I cannot bring to you a region
and say this is a region folks I cannot
point to a region region is of something
else I can put the space time and say
this is a region of space-time
I cannot say look I'm getting rid of
space-time I'm gonna show you just the
region no way no way that's it run on
out I will disagree on this but let's
keep moving okay anyways if we have a
region I'm saying that we have a
difference between the ball in the
region but look at I want you to look at
number 13 NASA what they illustrate in
their website number 13 NASA there we go
no it's the other 13 that that's your
that this one you can see that this
region so-called it's it's got an
opening and it goes into space they're
treating space as a physical object and
they're saying look there's a hole in
space and in that hole in space takes
you through a tunnel that you know could
take you to another universe for all
they care so they drill the hole through
space that's what they've done here how
did they do that if space is nothing
okay they had to turn space into
something and if you look at number 14
now I'll tell you what that's something
look at number 14 Davis this is David
Blair and this is what this physicist
so-called physicist says this is a PhD
by the way you can see all his all his
gold medals there
he says space is a very tangible
material with tangible properties like
stiffness and shape the most important
thing to keep in mind about Einstein's
universe is the fantastic stiffness of
space of the rubber sheet if you like
the stiffness of solid steel is about 10
to the 11 space has a magnitude of about
10 to the 43rd space is a billion
billion billion times stiffer than steel
wow that's hard to fill
I know because these are idiots there
that's fine now leaving it is because
they have a PhD they believe only on the
basis of authority Oh me also with the
PhD oh I gotta believe in whatever
nonsense he tells me but why would you
deny outright a physics that allows
place expansion I mean the light that we
received from distant galaxies the more
distant they are the more the light is
redshifted or blue shifted according to
the distance and that that's a that's a
good advance to believe that we are in
an expanding universe what what would
stretch the light right okay what what
do we need to do to create your what you
just said all we have to do is you know
change the frequency in other words the
number of links in the length of each
link in other words how long each link
is and how many links you have for a
given you know in this case for a given
length of rope that's what the equation
of C equals frequency times wavelength
does and if you change the frequency of
a rope of an object that is approaching
or getting farther away you don't have
to have any
face encroaching on you believe me
because face is nothing so the space
cannot do anything to you and astronauts
prove that everyday because they never
rub their ship you know their elbows
when they go out into space all that
exists are the objects not space but
they have to turn space into something
stiffer than steel to drill a hole
through it all right so you explain the
redshift of distant galaxies by rope
stretching assumption that's stretching
the ropes don't stretch all they do is
they curve around they get you know like
take a rope and you the more you torque
it the smaller gets the longer it gets
you know you all you have to do is
torque a rope and you'll see what
happens to the links you get more things
and you get the links are shorter and
that's why why is there a distance why
is there a distance dependence torquing
of the ropes as with galaxies that are
further and further away from us well
the first thing we have to understand is
that there are blue shifted galaxies and
they sweep that under the rug and
private is coming towards us it's not
it's not red shifted it's not getting
farther away it's coming towards us in
fact most of the galaxies in the local
group about 55 galaxies or so there and
most of them are coming towards us
they're blue shifted and so the question
is I thought space-time was expanding
pushing everything out how is it that
these galaxies are coming towards us and
that's where they cheat and at first
they rub it you know 99% of the people
who heard about the redshift don't even
know that there are galaxies that are
approaching us that's the first one but
those who know it they say oh yeah we
have an explanation for that
you see gravity overcomes the expansion
of space-time and hold it if it doesn't
for these what does it do for all of
them why doesn't gravity you know do it
for all galaxies I have a response for
you bill the equilibrium between the
dark matter and the dark energy the
bathroom
all right tweeze about this bunch so
let's keep moving well look at number 17
this is what these people are saying
look at number 17 here you have mass
working time this is their explanation
and they tell you that load you're not
supposed to take this literally don't
make fun of us you know but this is this
is their explanation they're saying mass
is bending space-time and they say well
you're not supposed to take the analogy
literally you know it's if you really
want to understand this you got to take
math at the university level that's
that's baloney that's absolute baloney
baloney argument I need a mechanism to
know what affected that star far away I
need a physical mechanism I can't do
what mass and I can't do it with
space-time and that's the problem the
problem is these people want to get away
saying look we can tell you how this
universe works and we won't let you
publish anything that violates our
qualitative explanation our physical
interpretations we say that it's mass
bending space-time and you say holding
masses of concept space in is a concept
oh you're taking it too literally you
got to take math in order to understand
it I don't need to take math I was
showing today a fellow here's a magnet
okay magnet here's a piece of metal okay
well we've seen this a million here
there it is okay okay now tell me some
how difficult is this how here we have
two pieces of metal right two pieces of
metal and now do you think you need to
go to college and learn algebra linear
algebra calculus and trigonometry and
who knows what else to know how a piece
of metal attracts another piece of metal
absolutely not
all you need to do is figure out what
invisible entity stands between these
two magnets that's it you have to make
an assumption of the physical object
that does this magic you don't need any
math whatsoever and once you figure out
what the mechanism is it's kid stuff
even kids will laugh at you
you know I sent you a look at number
three the donkey ball you can't make
that bigger
unfortunately no that's well I can air
artificially like this okay just so
people can see it better anyways the
point there is look at the first one in
in all cases you have a farmer pulling
on a donkey okay the first one has no
medium you can't see very well it's dark
it's too far away whatever the case you
don't see what's happening and you say
okay he's pulling on a donkey or the
donkeys approaching the guy which one
are you gonna propose are you gonna
propose particles is he's shooting balls
or rocks or something at the donkey is
he throwing waves at the donkey or is he
pulling on a rope which do you think you
would simulate this with how would you
explain this to an extraterrestrial for
example and the issue here is these
people want to do pull with particles
and do it with waves with transverse
waves that's the problem and and it
doesn't work it hasn't worked in 400
years since Williams and Newton got
added there's no way you're gonna do it
today I don't think he's sure with a
wave potentially pulling imagine that
you have a wave of certain properties
let's call it blue and red I send this
wave blue red blue red and imagine that
I'm a guy who likes to grab blue grab
blue and pull red of course I can induce
I can by sending you that wave I can I
can induce the reaction of oh man blue
is air Oh red is air and depending on my
property as a receiver of the wave the
wave could very well put me how does a
way but you're saying that love pulls
you a girl doesn't attract you
physically in the sense that she's
pulling on you like tugging at you no
you know it's like thrown showing the
donkey of carrot yeah the donkey will
come to you but does that mean the
carrot pulled on the donkey no it was
there is a better explanation okay
imagine I'm a guy with the magnet in my
end like this and all I do all my life
no matter what you do bill and whether
you send me a wave or not all I do is
and when there's no wave coming I'm just
a guy moving my hand with the magnet on
my fingers now when you send me a wave
there is a certain time at which a
magnetic force will be there and as I do
this I will pull myself in that
direction and so a wave can very well
carry negative potential from that
perspective if you give some property to
the receiver of the way maybe all that
thumbs in the universe are like grabbers
of gravity they're just looking for
these waves of gravity coming in that's
that's where the problem starts you have
to say wave of what second you mentioned
magnet yeah magnet will do that but you
got to know what the what how a magnet
attracts otherwise it's to say that a
magnet did it you haven't answered the
question you haven't said what is the
mechanism by which a magnet produces
this effect of attracting from a
distance that's what we want to explain
so yeah in fact you probably wave a
magnet like this one you know here by
wave that you know around and every time
it comes to this one you know if I move
this one around right yeah what I can
explain is that's what I get with a
magnet I can do it but I need to explain
how a magnet does it and with the wave
again you need to know what a wave is a
wave of what what is this wave so you
can't use the word wave wave is a verb
hey Jung Tarun's on the regular chapters
gave a name to my invention it's called
universal grabbers I'm a universal
grabber let's continue the universal
grabbers
well anyways no but that's one thing
that I find extremely weird and I have
to say I'm following you on the whole
dismissing of the space/time concept I
think it's it's a concept that will be
abolished one day I think it's kind of a
metaphor for what's going on and I don't
know what will replace it but something
is telling me that there's not literally
a spacetime because the number of
operation we add to add to space-time
which is Einstein saying it should be
curved and when some people would argue
Lorentz actually said it should be
curved and then Einstein comes in and
then the gravity can bend it and then
the customer that just comes in and it's
a it can be stretched by dark energy it
can be compressed or limited its
expansion by dark matter at this point I
think that we've essentially raped the
space-time and it will eventually
convert into another entity well the
question is what comes first the
extinction of man or or a change in our
notions of space-time but ue black hole
has several problems as far as I'm
concerned and these are conceptual
problems these are not things that I
need to verify in the lab or through the
telescope anyway you know I don't need
to pragmatically or empirically verify
any of this we need to know what a black
hole is and again I have a problem with
a two dimensional versus a three
dimensional black hole I have a problem
with a singularity I have a problem with
whether a black hole in other words a
star right because this is a
gravitational collapse the star is
collapsing on upon itself because it's
massive right and it's compressing
itself inwards and the question is does
it stop at a ball or does it continue
until it's a singularity and crushes all
matter out of existence well you'll find
you know PhDs out there saying what
crushes all matter out of existence but
it turns out we have a circular argument
because it turns out that if if mass is
the quantity of matter or a measure
of a quantity of matter and the black
hole crushes all matter out of existence
we should have no mass but see these
people get rid of the atoms they get rid
of the elephant and they keep the mass
and they say now the mass is a ghost a
spirit that's out there that's causing
havoc that's what we know personally I
don't think it gets them out of
existence I I think it's a it's a game
of word they're playing when they say
death out of existence in the sense that
as an external observer you will never
be able to see that atom again but I
don't believe that any information is
lost in the black hole since I believe
in the quantum information paradox I
don't believe that there is information
destroyed by the black hole in fact I
think it accumulates information and the
surface of its even to Rison yeah but
see that what you just said is not true
see because these people are saying what
do I have it here where you have these
PhD saying specifically that it crushes
all structure out of existence it's not
it's not a it's not it's not just a
wording it's it's real they believe that
it crushes it's crush the structure out
of exists and it wipes it ever and that
remains in other words they say that
between the event horizon and the
singularity there is nothing I think
that the the physicists you're talking
about I've abused language there and
they were at a time where they had not
examined the question in depth since
then we have we have solutions that
they've loved that can stack the
information at the surface of the event
horizon because of the infinity of
slowing down of time at this point and
we can send it back into the universe
using archaeans radiation and so I think
we have a more refined view of this
today and today they a modern physicist
a young physicist like the host of PBS
space time would not say it gets the
matter out of existence you would say it
is a format of transformation of the
matter it's because you don't like what
they're saying what they're saying is
crushes matter out of existence and we
can and this here is a study you know
they have a PhD in so-called physics
mathematical physics so who should we
believe the guy who says hey crushes
matter out of existence or you I mean do
you have a PhD in mathematical physics
I'm gonna trust him not you I mean I
know you're smart and you're an
intelligent guy but I gotta trust them
because he's got a PhD he's got our
authority you don't where's your medal
where's your work my only authority
stems from my regular chat in my
audience who keeps listening to me and
they know that I'm right deep inside all
right so let's just let's just agree on
this that there are some physicists who
have abused language about black holes
and the reality is very different
that being said is there something at
this center of galaxies that's pulling
stuff pulling with ropes let's say is
there is that the relationship between
the Sun and the planet the earth there's
a pool there right is there such a pool
at the center of our galaxy totally
different explanation for black holes
phenomena and for dark matter if you
look at in pictures I mean people will
look and again I'm not here to convince
people I want to make that clear I'm
here to show a mechanism that everybody
can visualize and then they reach their
own conclusion they believe or not it's
their problem
I'm gonna show a mechanism that you can
see with your own eyes I'm going to make
a movie using objects I'm going to show
a different version of what is known as
black hole and dark matter okay that's
what I'd like to do next and if you look
at number 24 because we need to walk
into this little by little number 24 the
dark okay this this is the problem here
this is this is a graph that shows that
as stars are farther away from the
center of a
Aleksey they travel faster you can see
the distance is greater and the speed is
greater okay and what the mathematicians
have done is throw kilograms in there
they say oh it's mass that's the only
variable they ever considered so they
say oh yeah if we put more mass we can
we can describe what's happening now to
explain because they had still haven't
explained anything all they did is be
able to describe mathematically why the
stars on the outer part of our galaxy
traveled just as fast or faster than the
ones on the inside okay so this is the
first problem that we have to solve the
second problem is number 25 the one that
goes after that and this is a mr. Ramesh
[Music]
Narayana and he's from Harvard and he
tells us of a problem he says the mass
of a supermassive black hole is related
to the mass of the the parent galaxy in
a very simple way the miraculous thing
is that all these points lie more or
less on a straight line in this plot
he's got a plot there we're going to see
that on the next picture in a minute and
it says there seems to be some relation
between the mass of the black hole and
the galaxy roughly the black hole seems
to be approximately a thousand times
less massive than the galaxy in which it
lives okay if you look at the next graph
the one that follows that one is a 25 I
think it is 26 Oh spectacular one yeah I
know there was what they're saying is
the more massive the center of a galaxy
this in this case it'd be the black hole
right that's what they're showing here
the more mass of the black hole the
bigger the galaxy in other words the
size of a galaxy or the mass of a galaxy
is related to the size or mass of the
black hole that's that's what what
they've shown through observation and
what we have to explain okay so we have
to explain these two things first why do
stars on the outside of a galaxy travel
faster than those on the inside and we
have to explain what is known as the
Bulge okay
galaxy bulge is this primary interesting
okay so let me explain that in a
different way than they do the first
thing we have to do is look at the next
one which is number 27 and what I want
to show here is that this is the solar
magnetic field okay and all I want to
show here is that the solar magnetic
field extends all the way to the bow
shock in other words it extends all the
to the heliosphere and outwards in other
words we're talking about something
that's humongously big the magnetic
field of the Sun now if you were
standing on Pluto looking at the Sun it
would look maybe like Venus like a
little thought in the stuff in the night
sky and and yet the magnetic field of
the Sun goes way beyond Pluto all the
way to what is known as again the bow
shock that whole region and it
interfaces with interstellar matter you
know in space and so all I want to show
here is the magnetic field is humongous
of the Sun you can see the Sun there is
a little pod and the magnetic field is
just outrageously big and if you look at
the next one the Galactic Jets number 28
same thing we even though it's I think
it's bigger than this but what they
illustrate here is that if that's a
galaxy you're seeing it's sideways like
a plate and the magnetic field extends
all the way to the edge of the galaxy I
say extends way beyond that it extends
way beyond that but let's assume this is
the case okay this is their burst and I
my version is that the magnetic field
extends all the way to other galaxies
that's how big the magnetic field of a
galaxy is not only is it big it's
powerful because it's made out of the
magnetic fields of every star in it
there are billions of stars in a galaxy
each one has
a magnetic field and the magnetic field
that the galaxy is in a way the
summation of all these fields okay so
I'm saying that the galaxy is has a very
powerful magnetic field and the
interesting part is that no mathematical
physicist talks about the magnetic field
when they talk about either dark matter
or black holes okay so now let's look at
the next one which is number 29 this is
my proposal mathematical physics says
that all particles are discrete there's
no connection between them I say that
all atoms are interconnected that's the
foundation okay that's my assumption
okay so I'm just saying that's my
assumption that's what I'm gonna work
off of and look at number 30 the
spiderweb we're gonna be putting a
spiderweb on top of the galaxies in
other words we're gonna say that all
atoms in in the universe as well as all
stars are interconnected like a
spiderweb
right there we're going to split put the
spiderweb on top of the galaxy just to
illustrate that all atoms are
interconnected all stars are
interconnected so when a galaxy rotates
it rotates like a like a bicycle wheel
in other words the spokes the hub and
the and the wheel all turn at the same
time and that explains why we don't need
any mass or anything like that all we
need is that to have all stars
interconnected and we can produce the
same effect that they do with mass okay
so basically what they do I guess is
they put some some form of mathematical
equation for gravity and they model an
entire galaxy and what happens is that
the the outside tends to spin much
slower than it really does in our
observations no it spins faster faster
galaxies at faster speeds and the stars
on the inside and I'm saying that a
galaxy rotates like a carousel because
all stars are it physically
interconnected only they're only in Y
the whole thing rotates as a single
piece okay that's the first one now and
this also explains the bulks issue
without putting any black holes in there
because what I'm saying here is the more
the more stars you have in a galaxy
which is what the Bulge issue is they
say the bigger the black hole then the
more field the more magnetic field that
a galaxy has and of course you know the
power inside the center of a galaxy
which is ten times bigger than another
galaxy is going to be greater and it's
just it's gonna be a function of the
magnetic field is going to be a function
of how many stars are in a galaxy I
don't need any mass all I need is to
show that the magnetic field of a galaxy
is greater when there is when there are
more stars that's all I need to show so
when I was young we did this little
magnetic experiment in which there were
iron filings that were allowing us to
see the magnetic field are you saying
earth to us that the bulges of galaxy is
essentially a visualization of the
magnetic field
it's a gases and other material that is
in the center of a galaxy through which
the magnetic field passes in other words
the magnetic you have sweeping threads
I'm gonna explain this in a second but
essentially a magnetic field consists of
threads that come from the ropes that
interconnect atoms these threads come
out loose they sweep around the galaxy
gazillions of them going through the
center of the galaxy and out from north
to south south to north whichever way
you want to look at it okay and really
they go from south to north if we go
with a conventional way and any material
any star in that region any gas any
particles you know they get pushed
around and there's this turbulence
inside the center of a galaxy in other
words this is what's causing that light
that these people took a picture of yeah
that's good I just want you to
understand the mechanism that I proposed
okay if you look at the next one which
is the ball number 31 I think it is yeah
this is a match are two ball in a
sweeping magnetic field this is here on
earth by the way it says it's a picture
but we see this every day if you put a
charged ball in a magnetic field
it'll spiral it'll go around nothing
there is no black hole in the middle of
that circular motion all we have is a
magnetic field sweeping downwards and
the the charged particle sweeps you know
goes around in circles we don't need any
black hole there okay look at the if you
look at the next picture you see the
same thing you see on the lower right
hand side the little ball that we just
saw and the magnetic field of the galaxy
which is sweeping threads is forcing or
compelling a star which is already a
charged object it's got a magnetic field
it's compelling it to move around in
circles we have the same phenomenon we
don't need any black hole we don't need
any mass none of that nonsense all we
have to do is look at the magnetic field
of a galaxy so you believe that the is
that is that something that most
physicists agree on that the rotation of
galaxies is of magnetic original no no
no because they do everything with mass
then they say oh yeah galaxy has a
magnetic field and that's all they say
and then they never use the magnetic
field again they do everything with mass
okay so the magnetic field that's the
problem okay if you go with the next one
so we go real quick through these and
that's a Cygnus yeah you see the here's
a rotating magnetic field and it's
pulling smoke it's pulling a gas because
smoke is made out of particles really
okay molecules you could say and this is
a rotating magnetic field and it's
drawing the smoke in there and the smoke
disappears into it I want you to see
that because that's exactly what we'll
see in the next one in the next picture
and again I'm I might be doubtful on
this
one is that not a when the effect there
no no this is it this is a rotating
magnetic field that the guy turns on and
he also makes it run faster and when he
does this you'll find that you know the
smoke is drawn in there it's done by the
magnetic field okay so but what I want
to show you look at the next picture the
one that's coming right up and we have
the same situation they say look what we
see is gases from the skin of a star and
it gets sucked into nowhere well yeah if
the magnetic field of a galaxy sweeps
them a star it has the potential of
ripping the gaseous skin of a star
without any mass being impulse if you
look at the next picture the one that
follows which is a different
interpretation we have two galaxies
their magnetic fields overlap and the
same effect can happen you can have
maybe a star whirling around nothing or
you can have the gases from its skin
being ripped off so there are different
these things need to be studied if
people want to look at an alternative to
this mass nonsense because and then I
say it's nonsense because mass is put in
by hand then they put kilograms in
they're artificially just to make the
equations come out right people are not
aware of that they hear dark matter
black holes and it's all they found
these objects no they haven't found
anything it's invisible it's it's
conveniently invisible and heavy all
right I mean I'm willing to I'm willing
to to believe that magnetism has been
ignored too much and that future models
of galaxies may may and involve magnetic
effects like we don't have right now
then let me let me because now people
might ask well how do you do this
magnetism with Rose because that is the
core of what I just explained let me
show you a little the sequence here
maybe six gifs that will put the
magnetism in their proper perspective
for anyone that
for himself because all they have to do
is look at the picture and say if the
mechanism they are observing is what
they observe with magnets and here is if
you go with the first one with the
number 35 here we see something really
incredible that very few people are
aware of people usually sprinkle iron
filings around a magnet that's on a desk
you know on the surface of a desk here
we see a magnet underwater and we can
see that so-called magnetic field is
something in motion it pulls one iron
filing at a time and it reflects what
James Maxwell said he said look I don't
know what it is but a magnetic field is
matter in motion
it's matter in motion some exotic matter
obviously but you know this this
magnetic field whatever it is it has the
ability of pulling one I'm finding at a
time underwater and and this shows that
it's a dynamic entity this so-called
magnetic field it's not something static
that just stands there you know holding
all these iron filings on top of your
desk no if you put it underwater it will
pull one at a time okay
so that I mean just just to give a
little opposition air what we might have
is yes there's a dynamic phenomenon
no no question the magnetic field could
always be the same however it could be
processed differently as the filings
block or interfere with some of it while
other filings may be more free depending
on their surrounding the environments at
the local filing may be influenced by
the filings around right do is proposed
a mechanism for how that's happening not
only the magnetic field of the galaxy
but here like we just saw a second ago
the magnetic field underwater what it's
doing to each iron filings and this one
I'm proposing again physical mechanism
if you go with the next one number 36
there this is the mechanism I proposed
for attraction and repulsion okay you
imagine two fellows they're skipping
rope the rope of the
one comes up the roof of the second one
comes down because they're both going
counterclockwise the two at the top and
the Rope of the guy on the Left latches
on to the Rope of the guy on the right
and pulls on it that's the mechanism I
proposed for attraction on the bottom we
see we turned this guy around and
obviously now he's spinning his rope
clockwise against the other guy who's
spinning it counterclockwise what do we
have now we have the ropes clashing
against each other and pushing each
other away
we have repulsion so this is very
interesting that's what I'm gonna be
explaining in a second here so if you go
with the next diff there okay what am I
talking about I'm saying that a magnet
has these rows of aligned molecules
right I put them here as atoms but you
can see what they're doing the rows are
facing you're facing along the rows
those little lines there the purple and
bring ones there Rose a magnet is
divided not into North Sound it's
divided into top and bottom regions the
top region has all the other rows of
what I call serpentines the rows of
molecules they're spinning in the same
direction on the top opposite to the
ones on the bottom and what you have is
the threads go through the center of the
magnet and outside you know in and out
the outside of the magnet and it forms
this pattern that is you know very
familiar to a lot of people with the
iron filings just crowding around the
motion of the threads and again what I'm
saying is a magnetic field is the
movement of threads the famous lines of
force that Faraday notice they're not
they're not abstract they're real lines
and physical threads that are moving
around the magnet okay that's my
polynomial a Marineris thing and now if
you go to the next one now you can see
the the mechanism if you have the two
guys on the top the two going clockwise
okay okay I'm sorry counter clockwise
the two on the bottom go clockwise okay
so you can see that on the
left magnet the guy on the top is
sweeping his rope
counterclockwise the guy in the bottom
goes counterclockwise same with two guys
on the right okay left and right the
same thing and what happens as the ropes
okay I'm sorry
the Rope of the guy comes up it latches
onto the Rope of the guy on that coming
down and in the case of the you've got
the same situation you have the threads
spinning around the upper left-hand part
of the Magna the upper part of the left
magnet is coming up when the upper right
one is coming down and latching onto it
the one on the bottom does exactly the
opposite as it comes up on the right and
I'm sorry on the left the other one
comes down on the right and so what you
have here is that situation where
they're latching onto each other and
pulling each other
one one one to the other what's
happening is as they get closer to each
other
more threads intervene because the
distance is less and now you're pulling
faster and faster and faster that's why
the you have the square of the distance
phenomenon between two magnets if you
look at the next one this is many
attracted here's you have repulsion you
turned one of the magnets around now you
have north south against south north and
again here you have the threads spinning
around the two top ones hit each other
and the two bottoms hit each other and
they repulse they push each other away
so this is the mechanism I'm proposing
for magnetism yeah fascinating very
interesting that we had already reviewed
some of those details so yeah I'm good
with this model it's it's a very
interesting take on the magnetism yeah
it's it's something that needs to be
investigated by people let me tell you
the problem Jeff the problem is that you
can't publicly I published my stuff
anyways but I had to publish it in China
but nobody reads it I guess they don't
they don't even read it in in English
over there
and I published my stuff but but the
issue is that you know in respectable
journals they will not allow you to give
a qualitative interpretation to anything
you have to only bring quantitative
analysis in other words equations they
don't want to see pictures pretty
pictures kindergarten pictures in your
in your brief because or your manuscript
because that's considered to
kindergarten ish so they said no we're
not interested in that you know we're
never gonna understand this universe all
we need is more money to keep breaking
you know smashing particles and we're
gonna continue with our equations and so
you cannot bring another you cannot
introduce another perspective to these
problems so that can they can be
investigated further that's yeah well
the problem that physicists will take
with that kind of model is is the rope
necessary because if I have a
mathematical description of fields that
do result in acceleration of the two
magnets then the rope is an extra thing
it's not it's like I don't see a rope so
there there there's no reason for me to
invent or up and if I have the
mathematics that describe the attraction
and repulsion then I've summarized
anything that the rope I thought is this
would bring to me yeah the donkey you
know what are we gonna use are we going
to continue using particles and waves
when you can have produce pull with
either one we can have you see the
problem with particles and waves is you
cannot produce action at a distance
that's what they've never been able to
explain they can explain push you know
particle hits particle they bounce away
no problem there but how do you produce
pull with particles I can't throw
particles that you would pull you you
have to have an elongated type of
mechanism or you're gonna have to put a
spirit in there in that same space all
right so let's continue yeah so you know
again though the problems I have with
the black hole are several you know I
have a list of problems with them one of
them I mentioned is the zero dimensional
two dimensional and three
mentioned how many dimensions does a
black hole has but it has all of the
above because they covered every base so
if you say well is it a hole yeah it's a
2-dimensional hole is there a ball yeah
that's a 3-dimensional ball it's
everything it's zero their mental
singularity it's everything and so
people don't even ask that question
anymore because the answer is all of the
above then you have the issue of you
know what is a black hole made of and
they ask this question to a PhD is the
BBC asked max tegmark asked me choukaku
some of these big names these
celebrities and mathematical physics and
ask him what is a black hole made of and
they all went I don't know you know and
the answer is it's made out of mass
that's what a black hole is made on it
right I mean some of them have charge
all right some of them have angular
momentum but all of them have mass
that's that's the key point of a of a
black hole so why didn't answer that he
should have said yeah it's made out of
mass well if they would have asked
answer that question then they would
have had a problem because they would
have said what do you mean it's made out
of mass what is mass I thought mass was
a concept and undefined concept all
right so definitely you take issue with
black holes now when you look at the
photo that they've taken what did what's
your take on it
is there a mass absorbing light in there
in the middle of the doughnut not a mass
what what you have is gases you have
particles you may have even a star
nearby and all of these are being swept
or curled around by the magnetic field
in other words by the magnetic threads
sweeping through the center of a galaxy
so if that's the center of the galaxy we
will concede that we will say that
that's the center and that black region
there is where you have the magnetic
field sweeping through there the the
bright part that's gases etc they say
it's falling inside a black hole
I don't think you need that all you have
to have is a magnetic field of the
threads sweeping through that smudge in
the center and you can produce the same
result since I'm sure you produces the
same effect with magnets here on earth
let's see if
understand correctly this would be the
center at which the big bulges of
magnetic fields pass therefore it's
violently magnetic in there and for that
reason any particle that finds it said
there would be automatically proposed
north or south and that's why we see an
empty space in the end it's empty
because it's been jetted away by
magnetism in fact if you look at which
one was it the jet look at the one that
says jet which is number because that
has a picture of it number you found it
yeah see the one on the left upper left
those are the Jets and if you read it
says that it's caused by the magnetic
field
so the Jets are supposed to be magnetic
fields which supposedly interact with a
black hole what we can get rid of the
black hole we don't need it those Jets
are the magnetic fields I mean a Sun has
some has jets you know they have all
these flares that come out you've seen
some pictures maybe someday and they
don't talk about black hole being in the
Sun all you have is these jets coming
out why because they're flares that are
carried by the threads in my case right
threads swinging around and these are
the famous Jets coming out of either the
Sun or the galaxy you don't need mass at
all
well bill that is a very solid
presentation you've done today because
it is that there's no answer from the
physicist as to how do you test between
the difference between magnetism and
gravity how would you know that that's a
black hole or that that is just an
effect of jet propulsion and I was
noting that they were often saying that
the black part of this doughnut is the
size it's much bigger than a theoretical
theoretically planned event horizon it's
three or four times bigger I believe
and so that would leave place for that
kind of magnetic mechanism to perhaps be
a better explanation yeah I think the
only way to resolve these issues and
every person has to good by himself you
know is try to rationalize it to
yourself I mean you you've got my
version it's a mechanism that I'm
proposing what do they propose whether
my I propose you ask them what is your
mechanism how does mass do this tell me
the the physical mechanism and if they
just say look it's just a description
mathematical description I have the
equation that's not enough because I
don't I need to know the mechanism how
the farmer pulls on the donkey you know
we can all understand that but if the
guy that says you know the the mass of
the elephant weighs down and and the you
know the space-time and and we get rid
of the elephant we get the kilograms we
have space-time but we don't know what
the mechanism is how it effects a star
far away then we got a problem because
we still don't have a mechanism and the
question mechanisms we have a few
reactions from the crowd white supreme
says ask Ben about static versus dynamic
forces horses or force forces I don't
know what a force is but whenever
someone defines words these are the
words I'll put them up front so that
people don't ask any question concerning
the word force the word time the word
energy mass and field are prohibited
they're they're forbidden you can't use
them in physics because they first
they've never been defined second their
mathematical jumped mumble jumble nobody
knows what those words mean all right
Vance Landry says what they're talking
about there's only two forces in the
universe by the way push and pull and
that's physics all this other stuff you
know gluons and you know weak force and
that's not such fascinating I love the
elementary ness of it Vance Landry says
it sounds like the e Michael Jones of
physics zoomer hub says the only truth
is my dick and the female booty I am an
animal and an animal with need
and space is irrelevant make babies and
do it do it with prestige double-dog
sans ten bucks thank you so much he says
when Michelson and Morley was
reconsidered decades later factoring in
relativity it's logical long alone no
longer disproved the ether theory have
you seen standing wave structure of
matter theory yeah I've seen the matter
theory we have to identify the physical
object the problem with the ether again
I've been covering it in fact in
presentations these last few days
the the ether if someone has to define
first it is the ether made out of
particles second is an infinite is the
ether the same thing a space or is is
ether some balls that are contained
within space are these two different
things are one and so all these
questions have to be answered before we
can deal with the ether and just on
michelson-morley i just want to make a
comment there that and again there are
different opinions on this but I read
that Michelson and Morley they
themselves did not believe that they
disproved the ether okay they themselves
and they felt that they confirmed it in
some way or another they just wrote
about it they had their own
interpretation on what the ether was but
everybody who looked at it especially if
it's Gerald was one of them you know
they said oh this this this does shows
that there is no ether then what is the
waving of light and so you know they
ended up with saying well light is the
undulation of nothing there it doesn't
need a medium to vibrate oh great when
they when they call the ether theory
totally debunked and has been
demonstrated fast I laugh in their face
because quantum field theory is
essentially an ether theory when you
start saying well there are fields
everywhere and that's how they work and
they have proper atabc
I'm sorry you just invented an ether not
only that I have a statement from a
Nobel Prize Laughlin
and he says look you know this stuff
that we have there this particles coming
in from the void virtual particles etc
it's an ether but we don't use the word
because it's taboo exactly that's one of
the great epic rezi in public education
physicists where they say we've debunked
the ether theory no no you you run back
to ether theory for decades until you
were back there double-dog says does jf
have big enough air to be a great
thinker well if I don't I can let them
grow and double-dog says rotating mask
in viscous hair creates an axial in
draft of hair that will suck things in
do you have a control for the smoke
experiment no I don't know it's very
hard to obtain such things that allow
you to show a different aspect of things
you know there's not too many people
doing what a magnetic field us to smoke
or the gas it'd be nice to be able to do
something like that so that we could
investigate these things but again
nobody's researching you saying nobody
cares about how the mother nature runs
her shop everybody just is doing
equations and getting paid for that and
you know going to Harvard into Cambridge
just to get a degree but not to get the
degree because it gives them knowledge
they just find people who can put them
in good jobs that's what it's all about
so nobody's really doing science
everybody's just doing you know pulling
a guy that said oh you believe like me
come on I'm gonna put you in my church
all right then as always it was a great
pleasure talking to you I think you made
a good case for this magnetic theory I
would put it as far as I'm concerned at
equal footing with the gravity theory of
black holes ii-i've never heard any
scientist debunk that properly and so
I'm gonna have to say I'm quite
impressed by this and I can't wait to
hear physicists comment on this was
there anything else you wanted to
discuss before we conclude
okay so she wants me to talk to you
about my pet theory of gravity so I am a
that is a good question by the way why
is it the if everything is blowing up if
space is growing its expanding
everything should be going farther and
farther away from each other we from the
Sun the moon from us etc but what's
happening is they say that again either
gravity or electromagnetism overcome
that force that's what they're saying so
they just put a fudge factor in there
and you solve all the problems you know
I never they never lose I actually did
I'm developing an alternative theory of
gravity whereby from a given mass in the
in space there are rays of expansion of
space however when this these rays
encounter matter they are blocked
essentially gravity would be a failure
of space to expand and so you have the
hurt and the Sun and between them
there's less space expansion then on the
side of them and I'm trying to check if
that could explain in orbit and
everything we know from gravity we can
do is try different theories and then
find out which one you know meets
William of oaken's criteria you know
just get the simplest one the one that
fits the facts etc but right now we
don't have anything from mathematical
physics they don't have an explanation
they don't have mechanisms that's the
problem there's nothing to compare
against because they don't they haven't
proposed anything they say we don't deal
with Megan if that's philosophy that's
ontology that's metaphysics we deal with
math that's the problem all right Ben it
was a pleasure talking to you I'll be
considering the show alone because I
have a couple of news to cover but you
are welcome again in the future
bill gayde is always an interesting
conversation there was